I posted a pin comment what opening
should I Crush mins with next
more like which opening should stockfish
crushman's with next
and the top reply was bomb gcloud
probably intending to spell bong clown
so anyway what I'm gonna do is use
stockfish
to try and beat mins
with a bong cloud
Bond Cloud might be too dubious of an
opening but it's pretty much as dubious
as to africabat this could go on YouTube
in the future
shout out to everyone watching in the
future on YouTube if there's any
openings you want to see me play against
mins let me know
and here we go so I have chess Bays off
to the side
and I'm going to start with
E4 and King E2 please don't play a
scandi
okay
and it already goes to minus 2.40
men's plays Knight F6
and I will admit I don't have really any
experience in the bond Cloud apart from
like occasionally watching hikaru's bong
Cloud speed runs
um
so we'll see how this goes Knight C3 I'm
following sawfish recommendation
yeah it's around round minus two
Knight C6
top move key one just putting the king
back so lost casting rights
Pawn D5 plane we'll go for a few
playable moves here let's go for ed5 and
Bishop E5 I think looks nice
or at least looks somewhat active
the position is pretty miserable because
white can't Castle but it's okay
try and make it uh
work out Queen D6
yeah let's develop Knight of three
Bishop F5 and there's gonna be moments
during this game where I'm gonna let
stockfish think
and I will share what stockfish is
calculating reconfigure this a little
bit but here we have stockfish this is
my uh my secret window it's giving minus
two point something
uh suggesting Bishop C4 Bishop C6
uh this looks absolutely terrible Knight
G5
wow look at this line okay let's go for
the the most exciting line Knight G5
7 Pawn
men's plays Bishop to E7
and another idea is to play Knight ge4
which looks okay
saving the knights
Bishop takes E4 Knight E4
and now Queen G6
and this is still heavily in Black's
favor but
okay White's still alive complain Knight
G3
thank you infinitum thank you vakus
appreciate the support
Knight F4 yeah mins is playing very very
strongly
um King F1 yeah we already lost casting
right so might as well use the king to
defend the pawn
castling his plane okay it's only minus
1.51 according to this eval bar
chess based sockfish is giving
minus 2.4
so it's it sees things at higher depth
and it's recommending
um let's move C3
the C3 or D3
C3 is a top move I'm going to play D3
makes a little bit more sense got the
bishop in
now Knight D4 oh dear
okay let's play Bishop D7
the top engine move
Rook 88
and now Bishop G4 okay this bishop is
going on a journey
the goal is not to die
Knight takes C2
mins going full throttle
okay the idea is G3 is very loose but we
do have Bishop F5 here
Queen C6
okay Bishop E4
the bishop has been centralized Rook D3
okay now both Queens are hanging wait
what is this Rook D3
I'm trying to understand
like what exactly is going on but it
looks like we can take the Rook first
and then take the queen
I mean our Rook is kind of hanging in
the end
yeah this does not look good okay
sawfish recommending King E2
now you take C1 Rook takes C1
and now Knight F5 so we're gonna win
back the knights
I I'm a little bit doubtful that
there's any chance to win as white
especially against a strong bot
but uh okay let's go for this
Rook d8
okay we have A3
at this point in survival Moon
I feel like mins is just going to
torture us though
getting revenge for the staffer Gambit
defeats
okay 93
C5
play Knight C4
yeah the problem is white is down
two Pawns
and it's hard to win anything back
but maybe there's some hope okay we have
Rook B3 okay idea Rook to B7
Rook D4 looks very strong
but I'll save the knights still ideas of
Rook B7
okay
it's hovering it's all about surviving
thank you love HS happy four years
okay Rook A7
I'm gonna see A4 so men's does hold on
to the pawn but the pawn is still a
Target Knight c3's idea
I really hope this doesn't turn into
like a 150 move game that would be
really painful
but knowing how engines play
they don't like to go for the threefold
so we could be here for a while Knight
C3
Rook D4 King e one
okay
thank you I'm nikox if you're just
joining I'm using
I've actually oh kind of cheating but
I'm disclosing I'm using stockfish
to play against men's
and the initial goal was to try and beat
mins with a bomb cloud
now the goal is to survive against men's
having played the Hmong cloud
not sure what the outcome is going to be
like we're like white is clearly much
worse here
but maybe there's still some hope
okay we can take on A4 let's take on A4
now only down one Pawn
the black pawn swarming down
care of D3
okay now we can go after the C Pawn
at least one of the Z Pawns
oh wow
they take C5
tactics I don't know if it works though
B4
we have triumphs in existing
King D2
Rook takes A3
yeah if we take the Rook we we lose the
pawn and then our own Rook
so have to go for Rook takes E5 here
we're still down upon in a rook ending
but maybe it's holdable
this is the third time this game playing
King E2
or okay for
okay let's go for Rook B5
Rook A2
at some point I might uh I might stop
using stockfish and try and hold the
position myself
is it gonna repeat three times
no it's toying with us
or is it
draw
wait was that not three times
one
wait
this was one
oh that was only two times
ah it was toying with us
oh again I feel like a cat toy
so it goes back to A7 but now okay now
we can play H4 and improve on the king's
side a little bit
King C6 let's go back to B8
and now King E3
I have very good news and we can see
this reflected in evalvar stockfish
giving almost complete zeros
it looks so bad like maybe a dozen moves
ago
but now
I think we've we've achieved the optimal
setup and it's not clear how black can
make any progress is there a way to
simplify um B5
King C5 Rook B7
[Music]
okay let's repeat
again a little bit of repetition
[Music]
it always repeats twice and then plays
something different
okay Rook D5 here now B6
so now it's three on four
H6
thank you cuddle Lingus appreciate the
prime sub
look at this move Rook B6
tagging along the third rank
uh but Rook G6 yeah the game
the game keeps going and I don't think I
really want to go for The Rook trade but
that would be losing
like most most of these kingpon endings
where one side is up a pawn is
is winning for that sign
but thankfully we can just wait like
Rook B7
G5 wow okay take
okay
I I have a bold decision
I'm gonna scratch stockfish I'm gonna
try and defend this position myself
so
I do see
um I mean engines giving full zeros I do
see this Top Line
I think it's enough to to hold on so I'm
I'm completely minimizing stockfish
and I'm gonna see if
I can hold such an end game
and this should be a pretty routine draw
but I'm having nightmares about
um who was it Anish giri like losing
something like this to nihal sarin
but okay come on it's just like
it looks so easy to defend
I just have to
keep my Rook back
now the king is cut off so that's an
even better sign
okay we might see this move but for the
time being
yeah the black king is completely cut
off
I'm a little bit scared that
I'm gonna get like tortured for a long
time
oh oh the king's marching
they're a legitimate idea here
that's still cut off like there's only
so much black can do
I'm still scared because all it takes is
one mistake to just lose to the bot
but now it's a waiting game
can I I don't think I can trade Brooks
yeah that that's definitely losing
it's a waiting game
repeat with me
it's already the second time that
position is occurring
I'm just gonna keep the king between F1
and G1
I'm waiting for it to blunder Rook D2
which will probably never happen
also when was the last Pawn push
was it G4 move 67
so according to the 50 move rule I move
117 if the structure stays the same and
Rooks aren't traded
it will be a draw
but that requires surviving another 30
moves
yeah I like The Rook cutting off
um I don't want the king to return
towards the Pawns
even though that would still probably be
a draw
yeah mins is uh
is very unsure what to do here
it's so funny it's like um
I really feel like a cat toy
it's like it's really toying with me
like it repeats every position two times
but never three times
but it's not actually eating the cat toy
which is good
I'm a cat toy that can't be eaten
also it really feels like we've had the
same position but the Rook keeps
changing places
how is this going to end oh okay tricky
I don't want to play King G1
also I don't want to even allow rookie
three
so I'll play this move
that small dip in the eval bar scared me
but it's all still okay
we're so close I'm 15 moves away from
the 50 move rule
uh do I have to move my Rook I guess I
do it's not a big deal though
still waiting
and it's really trying everything
eight more moves
oh it's gonna go back this way
but that should be fine
that's clever though
okay
maybe not
okay returns E8
wow it pushes a pawn
oh because Rook F3 is coming
okay this is a very easy draw
but is it gonna take the draw
wait what
let me
is it not going to take the draw
let me play this move how about
actually
[Music]
um
I'll just play this move
how is this gonna end
it's gonna play this
oh no
is it gonna play out Rook vs Rook
please don't
do we have to play another 50 moves
how do I force the trade please play
King F2
no
how long is this gonna take
if this ends up going on YouTube I might
speed up the video for the next
like 40 moves
wow it offered a rook train
that was unexpected
I wonder what it's gonna say
don't take my Rook ah
draw the prophecy must not be fulfilled
but what prophecy
and maybe the prophecy of beating
mittens with the bongland
what to do
at least uh okay at least it wasn't a
loss
I mean the position looks really bad for
a long time but uh it was interesting to
see the resourcefulness of stockfish
like accepted that okay there's no
casting rights
and the path of the bishop was pretty
Epic
um not sure if there's a clear blunder
it may have been like gradual
mistakes
but this is a really nice maneuver
Bishop D7
and this was still around like minus two
but
black never managed to actually convert
and then later
in the position was mishandled
around here
like maybe Rook A3 was a mistake
I'm not sure though
oh it does say there is one blunder
but how do I
how do I click it
because it says there's one blunder but
it refuses to say where the monitor was
I could click game review
but the last time I did this it didn't
load at all maybe maybe it's working
again
hey here we go
now it says zero blunders
oh the one blunder was King E2 obviously
yeah
yeah King E2
on move two
even though that should still be a book
opening
okay
um well that was fun
if this goes on YouTube I might have to
like trim down some parts but uh if this
goes on YouTube I hope you enjoyed it
uh sawfish manages to
not lose to mins
despite playing the bong cloud